- Good afternoon.
Welcome to re:Invent.
My name's Joe Cudby.
I'm a global go-to market lead
in our next gen dev
experience team here at AWS.
We're the folks that talk
to customers and partners
and so on about their software
development life cycles,
how to take advantage of AI in that space.
Today I'm joined very happy actually
to be joined with Krishna Kannan,
head of product for one of
our partners, Jellyfish,
and also Craig Dahlinger,
one of our joint customers with Genesys.
So let's dive in.
So today we've kind of got
a story in three parts.
I'm gonna tell part one,
which is how have we gone
from this conversation
of developer productivity
that we've had over the
past couple three years
to get to this place now
of talking about AI impact.
What does that journey look like?
How has that changed the
way we think about it?
Then I'm gonna hand over to Krishna
who's gonna talk about the way
that Jellyfish thinks about
this situation, right?
I'm gonna give you the Amazon perspective,
he's gonna give you the
Jellyfish perspective,
and then I'm very excited
to have Craig come up
and then share his
perspective as a customer.
So you're gonna get all three perspectives
in this next sort of 45, 50 minutes or so.
So I've had the pleasure
now of talking to customers
about this space for about three years.
So before we launched
CodeWhisper back in '23,
all the way through '24,
we've been really diving
deep into this space.
And so we've seen this
evolution in tooling, right?
In '23, we saw this idea of
like fancy auto complete,
and then we moved into
'24 with this idea of chat
and more complicated transactions
and interactions to get
through to '25 today.
And now what we're seeing is
all of these sort of more agent
agentic type experiences
with reasoned models
and other things, right?
They become much more
interesting types of experiences.
But it really has challenged this idea
of what does productivity
mean in this age of AI?
You know, when we first started
having these conversations
back in '23,
it was very much like the
developer productivity, right?
The productivity individual human.
At re:Invent in '23,
we started talking about
development productivity,
the productivity of the team, the system.
Last year at re:Invent,
we were very clear in sort of
talking about the distinction
between productivity and toil, right?
Kind of two sides of the same coin.
And then this year at New York Summit,
Amazon released our framework
for how we think about impact
in software development, right?
This idea of cost to serve.
And I'd be diving into
that a little bit later on.
So as the tools have evolved,
the conversations have evolved,
and with all of the conversation
this week about agents
and other types of experiences,
this is only gonna get more
interesting, more complicated,
depending on how you think about it.
So before we get started
on what kind of works,
there's some things
here that I come across
pretty consistently with customers
and this sort of idea of impact myths.
The first one, AI can
fix complexity. Nope.
If your processes are complicated,
lots of steps, lots of
people, lots of interactions,
AI can't fix that.
It's all about creating 100x engineers.
This also is not true.
We see a lot of stories,
maybe a bunch of things
on LinkedIn, right?
About people creating
applications by themselves.
But what we know is
that generally speaking,
you gravitate to the performance
of the team that you're on.
So yeah, you may have
one or two individuals
who are able to do amazing things,
but in the whole of your development org,
to gravitate to the poor
performance of the team.
Focusing on a single measure is enough.
Now, I wish that this were true.
I wish that there was some metric
that we could say like that's the one.
It is simply not the
case. It is not possible.
And as I go through the next
sort of 15 to 20 minutes or so,
I hope you'll get a sense why.
And then also understand
how these other platforms
and our customer
have sort of worked
with a range of metrics.
And then finally this idea
that we can just turn it on
and people will figure it out.
I've had a number of
conversations with customers
when we're talking about this idea
of enablement and training
and how you're gonna let your folks know
how all of these things work.
We're like, nah, I'm
just gonna turn it on.
Doesn't work.
If you look at things like
the DORA report for this year,
there's a lot of conversation there
about structured enablement.
We see it very much as well,
you cannot simply turn these things on
and hope it'll work out.
So that's kind of what doesn't work.
So Joe, what does?
So if there's only one thing
that I would hope you would take away
from this conversation, it's this,
and it's how we sort of think about
applying AI thoughtfully.
Yes, the software development,
but in many ways any process.
First off, this idea of
elimination, what can you eliminate?
I said AI can't fix complexity.
So how do we start to remove some
before we start doing other things?
Manual steps, tools,
processes, checklists,
all of those things.
What are the opportunities
to eliminate those things?
Also, manual interventions.
What are the things
that we found internally
was the very high number
of manual interventions
in pipelines.
How can you get rid of those things?
What do you need to fix to
make those things go away?
Automate, what is it
possible to automate with AI?
These are typically lower
value, repetitive, right?
Maybe relatively low
complexity type of things.
I would say standard
things like documentation,
test generation.
You've also probably heard us talk about
our Java JDK updates that we did.
So automating the sort
of runtime upgrades,
you'll see that in some of
our AWS transform agents.
Those are the things where
we think about automating
through the use of AI.
And then finally, assisting.
This really has been true, I think,
maybe in the last six or eight months
as the models have become better.
But how do we now take advantage of AI
running on your laptop as a dev,
as a thought partner, as an assistant,
as someone or something that
is capable of complexity
and thought and really
being able to achieve
high complexity infrequent tasks.
So, you'll hear me refer to
this, eliminate, automate,
and assist,
but it's a really good way to think about
where you are going to
prioritize and use AI.
So what are some accelerators for impact?
AI is a new way of working.
I've had a couple of
customer conversations
just this morning about this, right?
We are in a place where
everybody's journey
to your "aha" moment where you say,
"Wow, this AI thing is really cool."
Every individual's journey
is different, right?
It's very personal.
So how do we get to that point
where your devs are able to say,
ah, wow, this is really cool?
By giving them permission to play.
This is something that we
do here at Amazon a lot
and we have a leadership
principle, then I'll be curious,
which encourages us to take advantage,
experiment with these new kinds of tools.
What we know is that if
you have a development team
that is on a delivery schedule
and they have story points
and features to deliver,
and then you're asking them to rethink
the way they do the job at the same time,
it's not gonna work.
You have to be willing in the organization
to give your dev team some slack
in order to give them the brain space
to actually be able to play.
Software development is a team sport.
We know this internally,
and what we find is that
developers gravitate
to the performance of the
team as its itself, right?
It'll coalesce to the
performance of the team.
So as you're thinking about these things,
how do you accelerate the
performance of the entire team?
How do we focus on those
kinds of enablements,
that kind of activity, right?
To really drive acceleration.
Embracing sense making.
What do I mean by sense making?
So one of the things that
talking to customers even today
around legacy code
or bringing new developers
into existing projects
or even onboarding new developers
into your organization,
AI can speed up your new hires
or ability to onboard to projects,
to onboard into your organization.
When you're looking at legacy code
and you want to be able to
describe it, understand it,
there's an enormous amount
of value in using AI
in that role, right?
You'll see this showing up
in things like key rules,
steering documents,
all of these various ways
to make your AI better.
You can have your AI
help you do those things.
And encourage AI fluency.
What I mean by that?
So I'm gonna say that
we have the mechanics
of your developers
understanding how to Q, Kiro,
those kinds of tools,
but there is real value to
be had from understanding
more about the underpinnings of that.
My team and I have done
some really deep dives
with customers this year,
and what we found is that
this idea of AI fluency,
which I'll dive into more in a moment,
is really important to get
the most impact possible
out of these kinds of tools.
So, let's talk about
fluency for a little bit.
Two broad buckets here that I think of.
The first one is prompting.
Who heard of prompt
engineering a year ago, right?
It was a big thing.
Everyone was gonna be
like prompt engineers.
What we know that that's helpful.
And understanding how
to write a good prompt
is really valuable,
and the tools can't read your mind.
It's sort of trite to say
it, but it's very true.
And we have to work on this idea
of making the implicit explicit.
I've been an engineer pretty
much my entire career.
I have things in my head,
I don't say them out loud.
And I expect people to know.
AI can't read your mind in that same way.
We have to be precise.
Precision.
If you wanted to write test cases,
tell it write test cases
and the format that you want
and the framework that you use
will make it much, much more effective.
Structured problem solving.
Anyone heard of spec-driven development?
Show of hands, couple folks, right?
So what we're starting to see is moving,
and this happened with recent models,
is the models being able
to build actually a plan
for how they're gonna break things down
and do things in small pieces.
When we are interacting with models,
and I certainly have seen
this in the early days
where you would say something like,
build me a shopping cart.
Sure, but that's not precise.
It doesn't break it into tasks.
It doesn't really tell you what you want.
And what you're trying
to do is have the model
give you what you want and not off-road.
And the way you do that
is with more structured problem solving.
And then finally,
the thing that I think
a lot of folks forget
is you can ask the tools for help.
Hey, can you summarize this
conversation into a prompt?
What else do you need to know?
How else might we write this?
What is missing from this prompt, right?
Using the tools to help
yourself be better with them.
Really powerful.
So let's talk about context,
the other side of this.
Context. What else do you need to know?
So context engineering has
really been a conversation mainly
that I've seen sort of
in this year, really,
as the models have become better,
the context windows have
grown, the reasonings improved,
same problem occurs, right?
We're trying to use additional context
to make implicit explicit.
A couple of examples.
Q could create its own rules files,
Kiro can recreate steering documents.
You may have seen agents.md, right?
Ways to have context in your repos
that can help guide
these tools every time.
More is better, but only to a point.
In the same way, if you are
onboarding a new developer
into your projects,
you wouldn't necessarily
have them read every repo
and every application you've ever built.
You wouldn't ask them to
read all of your confluence.
What you would do would be point them
to more specific examples
that would be valuable.
That's the idea of getting
to the right context.
And you'll see a number of
innovations that we've had with Q
and Kiro this year around
constraining agents in the CLI,
being able to ping context,
being able to be more
specific with tool usage.
All of those things are trying to drive
to the right context, not just more.
MCP is incredibly powerful.
Where we were six or eight months ago was,
well, just more MCP tools, right?
I'm gonna give it connections
to everything I see.
But what we know is that I
can very quickly overwhelm
both the tools and the
models and everything else.
So it's very, very useful.
But be thoughtful.
And again, ask for help.
Which of these tools would be helpful?
What else do you need to know?
I have this other file, does
that make this better, right?
Engage in this idea of it being assistive
rather than you having
to prescribe everything.
Ask it how it can help
you be more effective.
So, gone through what doesn't work.
Some things that we know do work,
in order to get this idea
of how we then measure the impact, right?
We talked about how to make it better.
So measuring impact is a journey.
If any of you have followed the content
that we've had for the
past couple three years,
we've talked about this a lot.
There are industry frameworks
like DORA and SPACE,
a couple of my customer
meetings this morning,
We're talking about these same things.
I'm gonna talk about the Amazon framework,
cost to serve software,
which is something that we've explained
how we think about it.
And Krishna will show you this, right?
It is a basket of measures.
There are a number of metrics
and data points that
depending on where you,
and in fact your teams are
in their journey, will vary.
Qualitative and quantitative indicators
are incredibly valuable.
Qualitative, the why,
quantitative, the what, right?
So quantitative coming out of tools,
qualitative coming from your humans.
And there's a lot of value in
pulling those things together.
And I'll give you an
example in just a sec.
And then if I was gonna say to you today,
which is a lot of customers ask me,
Hey, we were looking for
gains in productivity.
I would say, well, how
do you baseline it today?
What tools do you have in place?
How do you think about a
measure productivity today?
My suspicion is I know many
of my customers say we don't.
It's ad hoc, we guess, we've
got some bits and pieces.
I suspect that a number of you today
are sitting here in that same boat.
You've got some idea, some
tooling, some data points.
But really the idea is that you
baseline where you are today
and then look at those
trends shift over time,
is the way to think about this.
And finally, they're both
leading and lagging indicators.
What we often find is the customers,
and a lot of times it's
the finance people,
want to jump to the ROI piece,
the quantitative impact.
But we haven't gone through
the leading indicators
around things like adoption, engagement.
How are people using
it? What's the feedback?
Do they feel good?
And so they're both lead,
and so I'll explain more about that.
But there's basically this idea of leading
and lagging indicators.
So, lemme give you an example
of how those things play out.
So let's assume you wanted to roll out
Kiro in your organization.
How might you use the metrics
and how might they change over time?
So in the first instance, what
you care about is adoption.
Who's got a license? Who's signed in?
Who has used the tool? Who's enabled it?
Has anyone got authentication problems?
You're working through all
of those basic things, right?
You're basically managing a rollout.
And what you want to do is
observe that early usage
and see if you can get any
interesting insights from it.
But at this stage,
it's a lot more about
does everybody have it?
Do they know how to use it?
Rather than trying to drive
to an ROA conversation.
Then we move to engagement.
Now I'm looking at different metrics.
Now what I'm looking at who
are my highly engaged humans?
Which are the teams that
have strong adoption,
which are the teams that don't, right?
You've heard me describe multiple times
that team is where this is,
you're looking to enable teams, right?
Team impact is important.
So which teams are on
board, which are not?
How are your individual teams
internally sharing wins?
Are you sharing wins?
Do you know of people
that have had some really
interesting stories?
And how can you then mitigate
low engagement, right?
Craig and I were talking
about this internally,
and he has a great story about how Genesys
was able to use these metrics to identify
and mitigate low engagement, right?
You might go and talk to people
and find out that it's something
simple you can remediate.
The qualitative, the why, surveys,
talking to people, walking the halls,
all things that we use internally
and we've seen customers use
to get to understand why.
Look over people's shoulders, right?
Really just observe and
understand what's happening.
And then finally we get
into the quantitative.
So now we're talking
about measuring impact
to your baselines.
In order to have
conversations with executives,
conversations with finance folks,
you need to be able to have a baseline
and then show some improvement.
Hey, we improved X to Y.
That's why we encourage you
to look at the quantitative
as a set of lagging indicators
after you know that people
are using the tools,
they're engaged and they enjoy it.
So, what about the tooling?
So if I think about the
tooling that comes from Kiro
and Q Developer,
and frankly what is likely to come from
all of these various agents
that we're all talking about,
it's going to be activity
that maps to the A
in the SPACE framework, right?
You'll notice there are
four other letters there
that we don't touch.
The data that we provide
can be used to drive
to sort of engage, figure out adoption,
figure out engagement to a point.
And I'll give you an idea of
the differences in a minute.
But what we cannot tell you,
because we don't see
enough of what's happening
inside your organizations,
is the AI impact, right?
You can't tell AI impact
simply by looking at the use of a tool.
You have to look at other things,
other baskets of measures,
other data sources
within your organization.
The other thing that's really interesting
and why this whole conversation
of developer productivity
has moved into AI impact,
is this idea of second order impacts.
When I talk to a lot of executives,
the idea of these tools is,
oh, can I write more code?
Sure, but where else is there
value? What else is happening?
We measure this internally,
I've talked for a number
of customers about it,
and it's this idea of
reduction of onboarding time.
How long does it take for a new developer
to reach the speed of
the team that they're on?
Time to first commit, time to
10th commit, typical measures.
But that can be a huge second
order impact of the use of AI.
Both of these apply here at Amazon.
We tend to move developers around
between projects quite frequently.
And so the ability to
reduce the time it takes
to take a new developer or
a developer onto a new team
and get them up to speed
is really important
and it's impactful for us.
The increase in skill flexibility
is something I was talking to earlier
when a customer was asking
me about skill makeup, right?
What do you think team makeup looks like?
We talk internally about a
couple different stories.
One of which is when we
were writing the QCLI,
we wanted to be able
to write that in Rust.
We had a shortage of Rust folks,
so we were able to take Q
basically and build itself,
and have experienced Rust
programmers do the code reviews.
So we're able to increase the
flexibility of the skills.
You might also see this, for example,
maybe you've got a shortage
of front end folks,
but you've got some
backend folks with time.
Is there opportunity to take
advantage of the tooling
as an assistant to expand the skillset,
increase flexibility.
That's a great second order impact.
Shifting right.
Shifting into Cloud operations.
We've seen a lot of customers
take advantage of tools
like Q and Kiro moving
into their Cloud ops teams.
Site reliability engineering,
Cloud operations, troubleshooting,
all of those things can
take advantage of AI,
context engineering, prompt engineering,
you could take advantage of those.
That's not directly related
to the developer necessarily.
And this would show up in
things like DORA metrics, right?
Other places that would
show you the impact of AI
in your Cloud ops team.
We also see it recently moving left
into product management organizations.
I've talked to a number of folks there
who are trying to understand
what's the value of Vibe Coding, right?
We've got technically
minded product managers
and product owners
who have been able to build prototypes,
and it takes a lot of time out
of that spec design process.
People can react to those.
How are you able to
represent that in the metrics
and data that you capture is
really interesting, right?
One of the things
that when the three of us
were talking about this,
one thing that came up consistently,
what are the projects that
would never have been done
if this tooling didn't exist?
We talk about internally,
there was a team at Amazon
that was responsible for
heating and air conditioning,
who needed some simple app built,
couldn't seem to get time,
so they were able to take AI
and build it themselves, right?
What are the opportunities there
to undertake projects that
would've never happened?
How do you find that? Represent
it, calculate it, right?
There's value there.
And then the other
thing that happens a lot
when I talk to customers,
especially ones who are
undergoing a lot of change
in their dev org,
is how do I isolate the impact of AI
relative to these other changes
that we're making, right?
We have a complicated system.
I might be doing a dev portal
and changing my tooling
and merging with a company.
All of these things add complexity.
So it's really intriguing, right?
We've gone from this idea
of an individual human
getting code completion
to we're able to take
advantage of essentially
the same tools in multiple
places in the organization
to drive a much larger AI impact.
So how do we do it, right?
Luckily here at Amazon we're
a large organization, right?
AWS Amazon, we have lots
of different businesses,
and so we tend to look around
and see where there are ideas of things
that have worked before.
Where can we learn?
And so what we looked around,
we looked at the supply chain work
that we've done with amazon.com
and this idea of cost to serve.
It's something we have talked
about in shareholder letters.
And so the cost to serve at Amazon
is all about this idea of
we have units, packages,
and customer delivery
and how can we reduce the
friction, delay, waste,
and defects in that process.
Anytime we can do that, we are
reducing the cost to serve.
The cost for us
to be able to get value
into our customer's hands.
And so we looked at this and we said, huh,
that's sort of intriguing,
because software, especially here,
is a complicated supply chain.
It's all kinds of different interactions.
We have everything from, you know,
hardware build to software
running on our hardware devices
to AWS to .com,
to all of these various businesses
using a variety of different things,
and it's complicated.
And so if we look at this opportunity
for friction, delay,
defects, and waste, anywhere,
that can improve our cost to serve.
Intriguing.
There is a science paper
and we've published more
information about this
if you really wanna dive into the science.
But the fundamental equation
is the cost to serve software
is the infrastructure costs,
the sort of the human and tool costs,
divided by the number of units.
The number of units will vary
if you are shipping a mobile app to an API
to a monolith to something else.
So the number of units is
really whatever the unit is
that your team typically
thinks of as a unit.
But ultimately,
this is something that
you can track over time
and it does allow for the complexity,
and it does allow the acknowledgement
of some of those second order
impacts that I described.
Luckily we have teams of
folks that can do this work,
but we were also able to
isolate some of the ways
that we improved
or we're able to reduce our cost to serve.
CICD. It works, we have data.
One of my colleagues was very happy
about being able to make that statement.
Managed templates and abstractions
is something we found to be really useful,
and of course, AI.
Any individual one of these was helpful,
but by bringing them all together,
we really were able to
drive a lot of value
and a lot of improvement
across our processes.
Ultimately, with a reduction of almost 16%
on our cost to serve
across the organization.
For a development
organization the size of ours,
that is a very material impact.
But you'll notice I didn't say
a coding companion did that.
This is the impact of change
across your software
development processes.
Now we're lucky that we
have the size and scale
and folks to be able to
do this for ourselves,
but what I'd love to do now is
call Krishna up to the stage
to talk you through how
our partner, Jellyfish,
thinks about this.
Krishna?
- Alright, thanks Joe.
My name's Krishna Kannan,
I work for Jellyfish.
I lead our product organization,
and we're really excited to be here
talking with our friends at Amazon
and our partners at Genesys
about measuring AI impact.
So I'm gonna take a half
step back here for a second
and talk about measuring
engineering productivity,
because that forms the backbone
of what we'll talk about
in terms of measuring AI.
So Jellyfish has been measuring
developer productivity
for several years now,
and thinking about how to do that.
And our approach has been
first to take a look at data
from your issue tracking system,
whether that's a Jira or a
linear app or an Azure DevOps,
and combine that with
your source control data.
And that gives us a couple things.
One, that gives us the business
context and project context
for what you're working on and why.
And then combine that with
the source control data,
like your GitHub or your Bitbucket,
helps us understand how long
it actually took to do that,
what language was in,
all the other metadata.
So we can create a signal
of what folks worked on
through that.
And then we combine that with
data from your HR system,
your CICD pipelines, your
error reports, incidents,
to really get a complete picture
of how engineering's happening
at your organization.
And so we've been doing this
for a number of years now,
and through that we produce
developer productivity metrics
among others.
And I expect many of you
are probably measuring
things like this already,
either with Jellyfish or a similar tool,
or maybe with something
that you built yourself
to understand things like throughput,
cycle time, team velocity.
And so having a good understanding
of engineering productivity
is a prerequisite, of course,
to measuring the impact
that comes from using AI.
So shifting gears here
into our approach for measuring AI impact.
I'll start with a few
general observations,
and then I'll present a
framework that we recommend,
you use that aligns with
what Joe's talked about
and with what Craig's gonna
share in a few minutes.
The first observation is
that across our database of,
you know, six to 700 customers,
you know, I'm hand
waving here a little bit,
but virtually every software
company we've talked to
has adopted AI at an organizational level.
There are a few straggler, of course,
but organizational adoption
is not the barrier today.
The barrier today is
that despite that 100%
organization adoption,
you really only see about
30% of those companies
benefiting at scale
from improved productivity
through AI tools.
You know, this is our conclusion.
This is Jellyfish's conclusion.
But if you look around at other
studies throughout software
or the knowledge economy as a whole,
you get very similar findings.
I read a BCG report just recently
where they interviewed a
public company executive
and found a very similar report.
So a couple things that we're seeing here.
First, Jellyfish did a state
of engineering management
report over the summer
where we talked to a ton
of CTOs, VPs, directors,
and interviewed them about
their AI journey thus far.
And so this is a qualitative statement,
but the question was
what percent improvement
in productivity are you getting today
or do you expect to get over
the next year through AI?
And the surprising thing here
was that it was a very open-ended question
that sort of begged for
an optimistic response.
And yet from that,
only 30% said they were getting
50% improvement or greater,
which of course, great for that 30%,
but you see that the bulk of the curve
is actually at 10 to 25 to
50% gains, which is good.
But that's not the expectation
that we're getting from the
hype over the last two years
about what AI could do.
We expect more from this.
We also see that of the companies
that have adopted AI fully
across their organization,
you actually do see fairly
dramatic improvements
in productivity.
This is a quantitative take here.
This is from another study we did
across 13,000 company
engineer week observations,
and found that over a 2x
gain in PRs per engineer
when you get to that top end of the curve.
So the improvement in
productivity is there,
yet many are still struggling.
And so we've been calling that
the AI paradox at Jellyfish
and try to help companies through that.
And so in thinking about that,
we interviewed a ton of companies,
talked to a lot of company leaders,
talked to a lot of developers,
and what we found
is that the gap between
organizational adoption
and individual adoption
is generally not one of effort
or interest in using the new tools, right?
Engineers by personality, training,
many of us are engineers here, of course,
are tinkerers and experimenters,
and we want to use new
tools, we want to use AI,
we want it to work.
But we're also many of us skeptics, right?
We're not gonna use a thing
'cause someone told us to.
that makes our jobs harder,
slower or worse.
So the key to unlocking greater
adoption and productivity
doesn't come through organizational
mandate or fiat, right?
It comes from understanding
what are the blockers,
and then how do we get past those blockers
to get true success.
So through our work with companies,
we identified a three-step
journey to go from adoption
to productivity
and then to business
outcomes in that order.
And then we generalize that
into an AI measurement framework.
And so I'm gonna talk about
what that framework is,
and I encourage folks
to hear the framework
and figure out how it can
work in their organization,
'cause it's not a specific
set of instructions
around metrics to track
or numbers to look at,
but it's a way of thinking
about those metrics
to try and drive success for you.
The first part of the
framework is adoption.
And when we say adoption,
we are really thinking about our engineers
using the AI tools that you've procured.
How many tools are they using?
How often are they using them?
And then what percent of their actual work
comes through the use of those tools.
So you can come up with
a whole litany of metrics
that sort of satisfy this criteria.
So I have an example I
wanna walk through with you.
This example here is from a sample company
that I worked with closely
and then anonymized for this purpose.
And what they did
was they said out of all the
potential adoption metrics,
they wanted to focus on
four, which is a good number,
two to five metrics is a good number.
They wanted to say first,
are we actually trying
enough different tools?
And so in their case they're trying five,
which is awesome.
Then they wanted to say,
are enough engineers using
something at least weekly
to begin to learn how it's working.
From that they wanted
to go to power usage,
which we equate to daily usage,
and then actual output from those folks.
So what percent of the work they're doing
was assisted by AI in some way.
So they selected four
that aligned with their sort of methodical
step-by-step approach,
and they compare them
each to an industry trend.
Now the good news is they
actually compare very favorably
to those industry trends
as you can see here.
But there's still room
for improvement, right?
Even though they have
44% of their organization
using AI daily,
what about the other 56%?
Why is that the case?
And so this is where segmenting the data
becomes your friend, right?
A naive organization might
go in and create a mandate
or some sort of demand about it.
But we recommend that you identify the 56%
that are not using AI daily
by segmenting your data,
cohorting your data,
and understanding is that specific teams,
specific locations, tenure of employee,
or if you could even understand
if it's a certain type of work
where AI is simply not effective
yet for your engineers.
And that's why that
connection between your GitHub
and your GIT repositories
and your issue tracking
is super important.
So even understand what types of projects
maybe AI is not being used,
where maybe it's less effective,
and maybe that's driving these numbers.
The second part of the
framework is adoption.
And so when we talk about adoption,
we're talk, excuse me, it's
productivity obviously.
The second part is productivity.
When we talk about productivity,
we're thinking about the actual outputs
from your engineering team.
So are you getting more
things through your process
per unit time?
So cycle time, throughput,
counts of commits, PRs, et cetera.
These are examples of productivity
of your engineering team.
Now, in our example here,
this sample company
centered on the pull request
as their atomic unit of measurement.
And it's important that they aligned
on what was important for them to measure.
Because there's a lot of different ways
you could approach this.
We've companies look at cycle time,
they might look at issue
throughput, epic throughput,
any number of things.
And it's important for your culture
to all be aligned on the same
thing that you wanna look at.
They chose pull requests
because that is something where
they are generally smaller,
they're voluminous enough that you know,
outliers and other
noise sort of drops out,
and you can get a good signal
on what productivity looks like.
And so they were looking at PR throughput
as their main metric here.
Now in this case,
despite the fact that
they're going faster,
they are trailing the industry trend.
And in this case,
our recommendation was
less about segmenting
on cohorts of individuals.
We assumed it was less of this group,
either junior or senior engineers,
this location or that location,
and much more likely
about the type of work.
'Cause what we found is that the age
and complexity of the
repo you're working in,
whether it's an old code
base or a new code base,
what type of project it is,
often matters more for productivity gains
once you've got that
base level of adoption
and engagement for your engineers.
And so in this case, we
recommended they segment
by the type of work they were looking at.
The final one is business outcomes.
And business outcomes that are
often the most misunderstood,
because this is really where
your organization's culture
and what you're trying to get
out of AI matters the most.
'Cause once you have people
using it through adoption,
they're shipping more work more quickly,
you're probably expecting
some sort of change to occur
in your company.
Now when Joe talked about
this a few minutes ago,
he talked about Amazon's
cost to serve model, right?
So that's just one way to
look at a business outcome is,
are you able to produce
software more cost effectively?
That would count as an outcome here.
Other outcomes might be
things like R and D savings,
they might be type of
work you're delivering
or you're delivering more innovation work
per unit time, et cetera.
And so that's what this
company was looking at as well.
This company was very concerned
with the amount of time
they were spending on maintenance work,
keeping the lights on
work, bug fixing work.
And so the entire goal of
driving AI and driving adoption
was less about cost for this company
and more about could they
produce more innovation roadmap
and growth features per
engineer than they could before.
And so in this case, they had
an improvement there of 37%,
which was awesome ahead of the trend.
Interestingly,
they wanted to do that
through using AI to fix bugs.
Now they were doing that,
but they actually trailed
the industry trend here
by a little bit.
So they were succeeding
at their top line goal
despite that intermediate
goal not being met.
So here there's an opportunity to find out
why were they were succeeding
despite the initial strategy
not actually playing out
the way they expected it to.
So this was good news.
They could then investigate that
and find out if they
could actually go faster
with the benefit here.
So before I pass it off to Craig,
one thing I wanna note here
at the end is, you know,
Joe talked about how
we went from, you know,
auto complete to code assist,
now to an agentic world.
And I think, you know,
the early data suggests
that there's a lot of talk about agents,
but the actual adoption of
those agents is not quite there
where the the code assist
tools might be yet,
but it's probably coming.
But the point is that
we actually don't know
what mode the AI tools will
take over the next 12 months,
let alone the next, you
know, 24 or 36 months.
So the framework that we've presented,
we really intend to be sort
of mode agnostic, right?
It doesn't matter if you're
using code complete or chat
or agents or augmentation,
if you're not adopting those tools,
seeing increased productivity
and then seeing some
type of business result
on the other end.
So regardless of what tool you adopt,
what mode it works in,
we recommend some type
of framework like this
to help measure progress and drive impact.
So with that, I'm gonna pass off to Craig
to take you through
the journey at Genesys.
- Thanks man.
Hi, my name is Craig Dahlinger,
I'm the senior director of
platform engineering at Genesys.
So I'm gonna walk you through,
basically take you through
what our journey was
when we first adopted Q.
Then I'm gonna show you
how we scaled all of it out
with as far as Jellyfish
with our reporting metrics.
And then along the way I'm
gonna share the lessons
we learned and how we
achieved where we're headed,
and kind of makeshift reporting
we did in the beginning
and why we're using Jellyfish now.
So when we first brought
Q on, our goal was simple.
We wanted to give developers
a boost in their productivity
and their velocity.
We also wanted a way to chip away
at some of the technical debt we had.
We wanted to take care of
some of the SDK migrations
going from AWS SDK v1 to v2,
even some deprecation of lambda
runtime, stuff like that.
So we started getting
some unexpected results
where we started getting
better documentation in repos.
We started getting much
stronger opportunities
for our unit testings.
So Q was being adopted,
developers were happy with it,
but the challenge was we didn't understand
how it was being used or who was using it,
and who was kind of the power
users or the idle users.
So the gap in visibility
was basically the
problem we need to solve.
How can I tell my devs
or the teams are actually engaged in Q
and getting the most out of it.
So we realized there was no clear way
to understand how they're
actually using it.
We started looking at the Q metrics.
We use AWS SSO for sign in.
So the users were Google IDs.
We couldn't really tell how
the engineers were engaged,
so we kind of hacked together
this kind of makeshift
to metrics database,
so we can tell our higher
ups how Q is being used.
We basically ended up
taking the data from Q,
piping it to Postgres,
and then our internal teams,
they started visualizing
everything in QuickSight.
But we started realizing
we can't scale that,
'cause every team lead
wanted a different view,
so we had to make all
different dashboards.
So it was becoming more
and more of a real pain
to scale that out to
everybody's different needs.
So in the end, we really
knew this was a stop gap,
and we needed something basically
automated enterprise level
for us to actually do the reporting on Q
and understand how our devs were using it.
So one of the Q check-ins with Amazon,
actually Joe was saying
that we're partnering with Jellyfish.
We already used Jellyfish
for our Jira intake
and seemed like a perfect
opportunity for us
to start using their AI dashboard.
So we joined the program,
we're able to basically
retire that Postgres stuff
and move the metrics right
over to the Jellyfish AI.
So the impact right now, we have it,
consumes all the queue data,
and basically give us our leadership
in the realtime stats on the Q.
And since they're already involved
in our Jira taxonomy information,
we were able to roll everything
up to our team service
and actually get the Jira taxonomy.
So as far as our leadership groups,
they were also able to understand
how Q is being used by their teams,
by their product taxonomy.
So it helps solve a lot of the questions
that were being asked.
Once we actually connected,
we basically were able to
see who our power users were,
who are idols.
It sparked a lot of conversation
with different team members,
how they wanted to use Jellyfish,
I mean how they wanted to use Q,
and people who were really
not adopting it that fast.
We were able to engage in conversation,
understand why they weren't.
So basically also answered a lot,
probably 90% of the questions
that were coming to my team
we were able to answer with the dashboard.
And something happened
that was really important
was it sparked a lot of
conversation with teams,
basically trying to see how AI
was being amplifying their work.
So it's not a replacement,
it's basically amplifying
the developer and engagement,
and then basically the
engagement with the teams leads
and the developers started
growing from there,
and we able to push Amazon
Q to adopt it faster.
So looking ahead, we basically embedded AI
across our entire software
development lifecycle.
AWS and Jellyfish,
they ensure our consistent unified metrics
across all our tools.
So it's one stop shop for dashboards.
It reduces the time
that the developers spend
on the mundane tasks.
And I usually tell my team members too,
like we're not replacing
developers, we're amplifying them.
So it's just another
tool in their tool belt
to make them better at
creating the features
that they want to create,
and help solve the hard
problems moving forward.
So what you're seeing there
is basically how AI metrics
helps us qualify the
real productivity gains.
Things like faster code
reviews, faster PRs.
The improvements are
theoretical, they're visible,
we can actually see the
teams making progress.
And it gave us something we've
been missing for a long time
is clear proof that AI
was helping individuals.
And if it wasn't helping individuals,
we knew we had engaged
in the conversations
to understand why it wasn't helping them.
Maybe it was prompt design,
maybe they just didn't want to use it.
So the point is the metrics
aren't black and white.
It engages you in
conversation with the devs.
Later on, Amazon Kiro came out,
we adopted that right away.
That took off.
Everyone in the team really liked it.
They integrated right into VS Code,
introduced spec-based
program and Vibe Coding.
So two modes.
We started seeing teams like
whip out really cool utilities
and tools,
but it really changed the developers
and how they thought about
building stuff with AI.
It was actually with spec-based program,
it's more structured and intentional.
Developers came more
efficient and productive.
And we make a point of describing Kiro
the same way we describe
all of our other AI tools.
It's an amplifier, it's not a replacement,
it's not just an assistant,
but we tell the devs just
another tool in your tool belt
to make you better.
We're still waiting on
some of the Kiro metrics.
Once we consume those,
we work with Jellyfish,
and Jellyfish will consume
those Kiro metrics.
So we'll have actually Q usage
and Kiro usage in one place.
So makes life a lot easier,
and everything also be
broken down the same way
is that for our team
taxonomy and everything.
So one unified dashboard,
one single space for usage adoption,
your return on investment
across the whole platform.
For us it meant teams
can choose the AI tools
they wanna work with,
and the leads and directs can
actually go to one dashboard
for reporting to see how
their actually developers
are using the tools.
So internally using Q in developer Kiro,
for us it's a journey.
AI's helping us build a culture internally
with creativity at the
forefront and speed.
And basically we wanna move
forward from experimentation
to basically real measurable
impact within the groups.
And I'm gonna hand it back to Joe now.
- Thank you, Craig.
So what are some key takeaways
from this conversation?
Some things I hope
you'll take away from it.
The first one is measuring
AI a journey, right?
You've heard me describe it,
you've heard Craig and and
Krishna all describe this.
So baseline what you have,
pick a framework and start, right?
It's not gonna get any better,
just go work with what you have.
And then think about this idea of leading
and lagging indicators, right?
A lot of the finance folks
are gonna want the
lagging indicators, right?
The ROI improvements, all of these things.
But what are the leading indicators
that will make sense in your organization
to help you move you forward?
Map your usage to your internal taxonomy?
I think one of the most interesting things
that I found working with Jellyfish,
is the ability to overlay the usage
across both organizational and product
and feature taxonomies.
It's been really interesting
to be able to see how adoption
and engagement works, right?
Impact is not gonna be universal
and it's not gonna be consistent.
So being able to explain to the execs,
like here's why this
team appears to be lower,
here's why this team appears to be faster,
and what are the lessons,
are incredibly important in
those kind of conversations.
And then as Craig talked about, right?
Think about your organization.
Having the good data enables
you to help leadership
understand what does and does not matter,
what is and is not relevant.
And finally, have a very clear
vision and a clear message.
So with that, thank you
very much for your time.
If you want to learn more,
we have a chalk talk session tomorrow,
which is myself and a colleague
where we're, you know,
gonna be able to talk about
all these various things more.
And if you want to learn
more about cost to serve,
there is a session tomorrow, DVT 207,
which is a session like this
where my colleagues from ASBX
will go super deep into
how we think about,
measure and manage our
cost to serve framework.
So with that, thank you very much.
Please enjoy re:Invent.
(audience clapping)